so eric fetty takes on a bit of a
makeshift miami bunch tonight
breaking ball from eric fetty a beauty
there's the slurvey curveball thing
we're talking about nice 3-0 comeback by
eric holden nats with a three-man
overshift against the left-handed jesus
sanchez
back door in the breaking ball
that was a guy trying to hit it 560 feet
on a two-strike count
two down
114 strikeout of the year for eric fetty
little backdoor slurvey curvy thing
and him lunging for the breaking ball
away kibum cuts it off
just a little glitch on the exchange but
he got it over there in time fed he has
to battle he gets a couple decays and a
ground ball out tonight lane thomas
alcitus escobar wants soto do up to take
on jesus lizardo who's making his ninth
start as a miami marlin tonight
change up swing at a miss strike three
put them away with a really good
changeup that had a lot of life late and
it was just sinking on him there's one
out here in the bottom of the first
inning here's juan soto now with nobody
on in two outs in the first inning 2-2
pitch soto swings and lofts one in the
year deep down the left field line
brinson in pursuit check that de la cruz
on the warning track makes the catch
three up three down
go the nationals in the first no score
now the batter is the catcher alex
jackson
now the pitch swing and a miss
struck him out
talked about fetty's off to a good start
strikeout wise as he did his last start
against miami a lot of swing and miss in
their lineup three men on the right side
against the left-handed hitting issan
diaz the wine of the 1-2 half-swing diaz
couldn't hold fourth strikeout for fede
welcome back josh bell is set to lead
things off 3-2 from luzardo
a bouncing ball to diaz who is the only
guy on the right side of the infield and
he's able to make the play we've been
telling you about his slick defense and
he's about 45 feet from the bag and he
just picked that one for out number one
big hand for number 11 ryan zimmerman as
he stands in here's the wine in the 3-1
swung on it high in the air to deep
right center field way back going going
good goodbye
a tremendous home run landing in the
second deck
in section 242 in right center field
bang
zoom goes the z-man
brian zimmerman ladies and gentlemen
there goes the no-hitter there goes the
shutout number 14 as bob said for ryan
the ending will start with that bat from
a two-time olympic medalist in two
drastically different sports eddie
alvarez switch hitting second baseman
upstairs for the strikeout and that's
three strikeouts in a row now for
marlin killer eric fetty the pitch
chisholm pops one up left side out goes
escobar in comes bell from deep escobar
will call and make the catch three up
three down inning for eric fetty after
two and a half the nationals won the
marlins nothing thomas a strikeout his
first time up the only one so far for
luzardo
he hooks this one left field corner
yeah it'll stay fair hits right at the
336 mark and cruising into second with
his seventh double as a net
is thomas with one out here in the third
so
for now they're at least going to pitch
to soto without the intentional walk
lazaro to the belt the left-hander to
the plate swinging a broken bat looper
right side base it through the hole
headed for the plate is thomas sanchez
up throwing coming home and it is too
high the air melts everybody the ball
off the backstop carrum's away soto is
going to go to second and now to third
as lizardo finally picks it up right by
the first base side dugout so the
nationals lead two to nothing on the rbi
single for juan soto so they pitch de
soto and they get burned soto picks up
rbi number 84. confetti coming in a
career era of 0.98 in five starts
against the marlins
swing and a miss
a grunt and a k
and it's number six kind of a backup
cutter there that worked nicely for him
watches just kind of goes the other way
sanchez thinks that's coming back over
the plate and it just keeps leaking to
the outer half the 2-2
swinging a soft ground ball up the first
base line a spinner handled by zimmerman
moving to his left and along the line
fields it eric fetty has worked three
consecutive one two three and he's
retired 11 in a row lewin diaz leads off
for the marlins in the fifth three-two
pitch diaz hammers one deep to right
field this baby's got a chance soto's
back track wall see ya one big swing of
the bat by leigh diaz has cut this
nationals lead in half it's 2-1 here in
the top of the fifth inning and this
time he keeps it fair the lead-off home
run and now darren jackson for the right
side
swing
gonna miss on a big curveball eric fetty
number seven
jackson twice
there's eddie alvarez
two two one outrunner holds swinging a
miss strikeout number eight for eric
fetty this one just stays up there it
works nicely formal cement mixer
chisholm for the count two and two it's
yet to swing the back
system to center
thomas back
and back and there
and the nats will hold on to their lead
by a thread
after a busy top of the fifth well
there's a big inning sitting out here
possibly
escobar online drive that diaz couldn't
reach
stevenson scores easily easily to third
is thomas
and there is a big inning possibility
now
the nats are back up by two i mean good
for this guy right first time back in
the big leagues in a few years look at
the extension there the plate coverage
we see it all the time i think the best
bad ball hitter for the nets easily
they're gonna walk soto so bell batting
right handed with the bases loaded now
the kick in the pitch inside low ball
four
through the slider and he walked bell
will pick up his 82nd rba of the year
the easy way as thomas comes in to score
from third nationals now lead it by the
score of four to one and here is ryan
zimmerman the 1-1 pitch is swung on and
hit on the ground toward short chisholm
to second for one a throw to first is in
time double play ryan zimmerman wraps
into a six four three double play inning
over the nationals get two more play
with diaz leads off for miami leiwan has
played the lone run for the marlins
tonight a solo shot his fourth of the
season back in the fifth inning here's a
swing and a drive deep right field leigh
diaz has done it again
a bomb into the upper tank in right
field and now it's 4-2 washington here
in the top of the seventh inning that
ball was tattooed and jp you just said
it looks like this young man is getting
hot
use a mound visit here to discuss panic
to right well hit soto back and he's got
it what a play
then he'll throw it out of the ballpark
to his buddies in the bullpen that was a
great route a great jump i thought
initially the ball might beat him but
fully extended makes the running catch
and then throws it in the bullpen the
same play
the nationals have started the eighth
inning with three singles they're loaded
with nobody out and jordy mercer who's
been on the injured list for quite a
while couldn't ask for a better
situation way outside jordy mercer walks
to an rbi second time the nats have had
that happen tonight and it's five to two
nobody out and lane thomas is next
williams kicks and delivers thomas tanks
low and away ball four and another run
is walked across the plate so here's
alcadies escobar
reaching for that one
he did that's deep enough for garcia he
scampers on the other runners freeze
and the nets lead seven to two so now
juan soto having a good night at the
plate
soda to center
it's another hit
mercer had to hold up now the ball's
booted so two runners will move up i
don't think juan will get an rbi because
the runners were freezing but he'll
definitely get another hit and he's
three for four brenson on the exchange
lack of concentration he's been standing
out there watching ball after ball after
ball
and that's what happens when you work
slow and don't throw strikes and sandy
leone now will come up as a pinch hitter
swing and a miss
tag him and the ball game's over and the
nets finally bust this thing open late
so they win it eight to two